receding gums are not attractive
symptoms include tooth sensitivity and
oral health issues but a lot of people
avoid gum grafting surgery because
they've heard
it's painful and i did this about 20
years ago and it was
after years of research though dr john
chao developed
pinhole gum rejuvenation the first
minimally invasive treatment to correct
gum recession he joins us now to tell us
how this works thanks dr chow for
joining us
thank you for having me so why should
people care about receding gums in the
first place
well that's a really great question
receiving gums
for for one thing are unaffected
and they can also cause true sensitivity
and lead to other oral tissues as you
mentioned
but the aging process and health
problems are also factors
receiving gums can affect anybody at any
age even younger folks
so you have this new treatment it's
pinhole gum rejuvenation
how does it work well
pillow gum rejuvenation being the first
minimally invasive treatment for
receiving gums
that requires no scalpels no sitting
and minimum downtime the entire
procedure is done through
tiny pinholes made in the gums first
the gum is numb with a local anesthetic
then using special instruments that i
designed they trained dentists
freeze the gum tissue and guides the
gums to cover the exposed roots
the pinholes heal quickly and most
patients report
little or no pain and virtually no
downtime
this encourages people treatment yeah
for anyone who has had a gum graft this
is revolutionary and they understand how
big a deal this
is what inspired you to come up with
this or how did you
come up with well mostly like most
inventions peter was developed
to build a particular need that i saw in
my own patients
like like you who had experienced
difficulties
with recovery painful painful
symptoms and long recovery time so
this was what inspired me to begin
research
and development of the piano technique
to date i personally trained over 3500
dentists
from across the country and around the
world due to the demand
for dentists i'm continuing training
courses for new online classes for
dentists people can find a trained
dentist now
in most cities and towns across the usa
of course
including beautiful las vegas you showed
us a little bit about how it works what
is the recovery time in this case
recovery time is practically zero
patients love the results and they see
the results
instantly the same appointment and
because there's no cutting there's no
suturing
uh there's hardly any uh there's hardly
any symptoms
uh the next day or also there's hardly
any downtime
then most they need maybe it's one or
two timeouts and that's it
it's fantastic i know a lot of viewers
going to want to know how they can find
this
where can people learn more about it or
find out if their dentist does it
okay then go to pinhole gum
rejuvenation.com
and they can find dentists who are
uh trained in the pinhole technique and
trained that and
dentists with needing treatment needing
to learn about the technique
can uh i can also find information on
the response
dr chow great stuff thanks for joining
us today really appreciate it
okay thank you for having me all right
rocky over to